oh my God
Captain Jack Sparrow he happens to be
right close to the top and the bottom at
the same time I'll be
Johnny Depp making dreams come true for
a special fan I reckon I'll take Jack
with me forever you know I'll always be
somewhat accessible yeah the actor slips
right back into Captain Jack Sparrow
[Music]
all right
in moments shared to Instagram a Pirates
of the Caribbean fan gets emotional as
Johnny offers a hug very nice
and later he channels his trademark
character
Oh Captain Jack Sparrow he happens to be
right close to the top and the bottom at
the same time
itself
it's another three uniforms absolutely
The Immortal Captain Sparrow well at
that I've loved playing Captain Jack so
much I feel privileged to be able to do
this for a living the touching encounter
comes as Johnny enters a new chapter
following the court win in his
defamation trial against ex-wife Amber
Heard do you find that Mr Depp has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes
in the aftermath Johnny's less pirate
can I see that and more of a rock star
going on tour with Jeff Beck Jeff
very
simply and kindly took me in lived with
him for months and months and months and
then we went on the first tour together
and so for me having had to deal with
other things at the same time
wants those things
you know or down the road
and you drop into the tour
well you it's like your home meanwhile
he's still making time for his biggest
fans
he happens to be right close to the top
and the bottom at the same time
I suppose
foreign